jean luc mélenchon est l'invité ce soir
de preuves par 3 bonsoir merci d'être
avec nous député européen vous militez
en ce moment pour une sixième république
et mickaël à metz de public sénat
viendra nous expliquer un petit peu vos
propositions institutionnelles il vous
interrogera sur ce sujet qu'at-elle
prison de la haye afp le partenaire de
cette émission viendra nous parler des
élections départementales de la gauche
qui part divisée justement sur ces
élections départementales jean luc
mélenchon à trois semaines du premier
tour de scrutin une évidence s'impose
c'est le fn qui fait la course en tête
et qui recueille pour l'instant un tiers
des intentions de vote pour l'instant
ceux qui ne l'auraient pas compris son
réel mots que tu carreaux leur répète
depuis des mois donc en avant je me
demande même si ça sert à quelque chose
de faire l'élection pourrait tout faire
le commentaire sur la victoire à la fois
la gauche est incapable d'enrayer cette
montée du front national la gauche de
quoi parlez vous ça peut pas être le
parti socialiste c'est lui qui crée le
désordre économique aujourd'hui parce
que c'est lui qui est au pouvoir mais
avant c'était monsieur sarkozy et même
motif même peine
bon le principal pourvoyeur de voix du
front national c'est ceux qui sont dans
une attitude de servilité devant la
commission européenne et les politiques
alain posent à la france qui sont
contraires à son intérêt mal à avaler
une fois qu'on a dit ça après bug la
galère maintenant ça fait quelque chose
comme depuis le mois de janvier contre
allumé une chaîne de radio de télévision
ou écouter une radio sans entente du
matin au soir
le récit sur l'abomination de
l'islamisme que la france est un pays
antisémite et 9 ans sont les médias qui
font monter le front national
oui bien sûr ça joue un très grand rôle
parce que les médias sont un fait
contemporain très important les gens
construisent leur pensée à partir de ce
qu'ils voient à la télévision à la radio
dont les médias ont une responsabilité
évidemment ensuite il ya la
responsabilité principale c'est ce qui
crée la situation qui est favorable ça
c'est pas les médias les médias il
accompagne le mouvement et puis bon pour
l'instant c'est une recette qui fait ce
qui fait du buzz quoi on se fait peur
les petit bourgeois s'affolent bon ça
occupe
mais le fond de la faire c'est la
politique ensuite il ya le rôle oui des
méga de la machine a répété du matin
elle relance et des politiques
peut-être de vous aussi qu'il n'arrivait
peut-être pas à rassurer et à tiens
bien sûr mais non mais ça nous sommes
près de moi s'il vous plaît le fou et
que je me batte devant vous pour que
vous ayez la satisfaction
non c'est pas comme ça que la sphère se
présente dans les grandes périodes de
crise les protagonistes vont se cherche
et là où est la confusion et et le vide
la confusion créée l'effondrement et la
clarté non alors madame le pen est dans
une attitude extrêmement clair elle est
en train de siphonner les voix de la
droite et à partir de là le feront que
l'on pourrait opposer qu'on nous propose
ne tient pas debout
on nous dit qu'il faut faire lui dit et
alors l'unité nationale
voilà vendre il n'y a qu'à faire ça et
on aggravera encore les choses parce que
ça revient à faire en quelque sorte deux
camps ceux qui protesterait ce serait le
front national et ceux qui seraient
d'accord avec le système se seraient
tous les autres d'ailleurs
quand les socialistes nous parla nous
d'unités ils ne nous disent pas pour
faire l'unité nous allons changer ceci
ou cela nous n'allons plus faire la loi
à maquereau nous ne ferons pas telle ou
telle loi antisociale
non ils nous demandent de nous taire de
nous mettre en rang derrière eux outre
que ce n'est même pas imaginable mais ça
ne servirait strictement à rien on va
reparler de ces élections
départementales dans la deuxième partie
de l'émission avec elle tu as bien
normal à exclure ce n'est au courant
qu'il ya des élections départementales
le pouvoir peu ce qu'il faut pour créer
les pires qu'on est là on va consacrer
tout à l'heure justement dix minutes une
dizaine de minutes à ces élections de
l'oriental parlons de l'europe puisque
vous êtes député européen est-ce que
c'est l'union européenne qui a sauvé la
grèce qui va donc rester dans la zone
euro non l'union européenne a saccagé la
grèce l'a humilié avant c'est à dire que
lorsque la crise s'est déclenchée avec
le gouvernement du ps de george
papandréou qui s'est immédiatement
soumis aux injonctions du marché le pays
a été dévasté
on lui a appliquée dit plan d'austérité
la situation ne s'est nullement
améliorée elle s'est aggravée
la dette a augmenté les souffrances sont
telles que personne ne les imagine bon
augmentation de la mortalité infantile
augmentation des suicides le pays et
saccagé et il a perdu 25%
de sa capacité à créer de la richesse
chaque année donc le pays est dévasté
bien maintenant nous avons obtenu dans
la rencontre de leur groupe et avec le
conseil de gouvernement la grèce a
obtenu un délai de quatre mois pour
respirer
elle l'a fait dans des conditions
extraordinaires de sang froid parce que
monsieur chat aux bleus on y voit un
compromis entre les promesses de
campagne et puis les volontés ainsi de
l'union européenne
oui le compromis que qu'a fait le
gouvernement grec c'est le compromis
maximum il a dit nous nous acceptons
nous reconnaissons la dette déjà pas mal
nous nous acceptons de la payer mais
nous demandons être maître de la
politique pour répondre à cet objectif
c'est à dire que nous ne croyons pas dit
le gouvernement grec et je lui donne
raison que c'est par l'austérité qu'on
va arriver à régler le problème de la
dette passe un tiers de la population
d'alexis oui j'ai vu ça il ya des
journaux qu'on dit ça mais bon c'est pas
trés ça n'a aucune importance ce qui
compte c'est la façon avec laquelle les
grecs comprennent ce que fait leur
gouvernement est pour l'instant dans les
enquêtes d'opinion n'a pas d'importance
mais vous pensez qu'il a cédé à l'union
européenne aux institutions comme on lit
maintenant je ne vois pas ça comme ça
mais je trouve que le terme capitulation
correspond à deux intérêts les
gauchistes qui ne sont jamais contents
de rien et tu trouves que c'est jamais
assez et puis toute la droite qui a pris
peur de voir un peuple se dresser faire
une politique contraire il fallait à
tout prix donner l'idée que personne ne
peut rien contre ça et d'ailleurs un
homme aussi détestable et méprisable à
maints égards que monsieur chat aux
bleus avec ce tout le saviez litres des
finances allemand oui c'est ça le
ministre des finances allemand a dit à
la femme j'attends de voir ce qu'ils
vont expliquer à leurs électeurs parce
que pour lui ça le faisait jubilé de
voir qu'on peut humilier un pays où vous
savez qu'ils nous appellent le club med
en parlant des pays du sud de l'europe
donc non moi je mets un bon point à
décerner à angela merkel qui finalement
a cherché un compromis avec la grèce
alors que l'opinion publique est de plus
en plus hostile non je ne suis pas du
tout d'accord pour lui donner un bon
poids je pense que là l'europe toute
entière est malade de la politique
allemande ce qui va se traduire et se
voir de plus en plus clairement
l'allemagne le gouvernement allemand est
une sorte de poison pour l'europe
il inflige à tout le monde une politique
et sens
bonne pour l'allemagne mais n'est pas
bonne du tout pour les autres peuples
d'europe elle a au contraire elle a joué
un rôle qu'on connaît qui est assez
classique à la lâcher chat aux bleus qui
s'est comporté d'une manière tellement
odieuse qu'il ne pouvait plus être dans
la même pièce que monsieur bara food is
le représentant grec le ministre des
finances a innervé d'autres milices des
finances au vert et bien vous avez l'air
d'être bien informé moi c'est pas
l'information g d'accord je pense qu'un
ministre qui vient défendre un pays qui
représente 2% de la richesse seulement
qui est dans un état si misérable mérite
de la considération
surtout quand le peuple vient de le
désigner il a été regardé de haut il
avait très peu d'alliés je pense que il
en avait quasiment pas les français
étaient les mieux disposés parce que ce
n'est pas l'intérêt de la france que de
voir humilié la grèce mais il a été très
isolé et il a fait un magnifique travail
nous ils ont obtenu quatre mois de délai
maintenant je vais vous dire si au bout
de quatre mois
madame merkel monsieur chat aux bleus et
les pays vassaux de l'allemagne décide
c'est à dire les autres pays de l'union
européenne n'ont pas tous les autres
ceux qui ont des dettes qui dépendent du
marché et ceux qui sont à l'aise qu'ils
sont tous à vassaliser d'après moi c'est
une thèse d'économie que je pourrais
développer devant vous mais tout c'est
tout si tous ces gens là décide quelque
chose qui n'existe pas dans les statuts
européens qui est de chasser la grèce de
l'euro est bien rire a bien qui rira le
dernier
parce que je crains que ceux qui ont
pris l'euro comme monnaie de réserve je
pense aux chinois je pense aux russes
apprécient assez médiocrement le fait
que la zone euro soit une zone à
géométrie variable
à partir du moment où un pays fussent un
seul sera éjecté il y aura un doute sur
la validité de la monnaie unique
européenne et à partir de là ce sera le
début de la fin alors la france aussi
est dans la seringue si on peut dire
puisque bruxelles serre la vis exige un
effort de redressement structurel
important maintenant pour la france vous
dites fini l'indulgence
non mais
mais qu'est ce que c'est que cette
histoire qui est cette bande de mariole
qui prend des décisions à la place du
peuple français mais enfin ce n'est pas
sérieux
est ce que vous savez ce que c'est que
cette politique d'ajustement structurel
c'est ces politiques ont échoué dans
toute l'amérique latine
maintenant qu'ils marchent par exemple
en allemagne non il ne marche pas vous
en allemagne en espagne aux non plus on
n'est ce pas et lui les derniers
chiffres du chômage
madame si vous prenez quelqu'un que vous
avez laissé mouvant et tout d'un coup il
prend un verre d'eau vous dites ah ça va
mieux il bouge
ce que nous voyons ce sont les spasmes à
l'intérieur d'une agonie l'espagne nos
soins
l'espagne ne peut pas se relever
personne ne peut se relever avec une
politique mais la vision de croissance
pour cette année l'espagne par doit pas
meilleure prévision de croissance en
arabe ça veut dire combien
chère madame combien ce n'est plus les
chiffres en tête mais un des meilleurs
taux je voulais dire c'est non pas
l'oublier pas forcément en tête ça va
être du coi 1% à 2 mais qui resteront
bien voilà et bien voilà avant contenter
de peu par mois
moi j'ai à faire un grand peuple et
français 65 millions au moment de
travail tous les ans nous avons 600 mhz
il faut dire oui à l'europe
non il faut bien les réformes
structurelles qui sont demandés
notamment par le commissaire
d'abord celui ci oui ma pierre moscovici
c'est un coup il a un côté un coup il
est de l'autre façon il est à chaque
fois c'est des désastres mais c'est pas
comme ça qu'il faut voir la faire c'est
pas dire non à l'europe c'est à dire non
à cette politique européenne et à ses
traités européens
est ce que vous vous rendez compte de la
monstruosité qu'a dit monsieur jonker en
disant il n'y a pas de vote démocratique
contre les traités européens
ça s'appelle qu'est ce que ça veut dire
ça veut dire que les états maintenant
une souveraineté limitée vous avez le
droit d'être d'accord et de dire c'est
la politique allemande est génial mais
moi j'ai le droit de dire je ne veux pas
de ça pour mon pays mon pays est libre
il doit être indépendant et je suis prêt
à partager avec les autres la
responsabilité mais pas au point de
subir leur prétendue politiques
d'ajustement structurel qui est une
catastrophe économique ça ne marche
nulle part et comme vous me dites ah oui
mais ça marche en allemagne je vous
réponds non
il y à 15 millions de pauvres en
allemagne qui est le pays le plus riche
de la zone euro ça n'a l'air de choquer
personne
vous avez des gens qui sont obligés de
travailler en euros de l'heure ça n'a
l'air de choquer personne
donc quand même comment sont un peu à
prendre du recul sur cette situation
et arrêtons
admirez ce qui n'a rien d'admirable
d'abord si les allemands paient
eux-mêmes leurs dettes dans l'histoire
ça changerait beaucoup l'histoire du
continent
ils ne le font jamais ils ne connaissent
que les coups de force et l'esprit de
système u nantes aucune souplesse pour
comprendre que si on continue comme ça
nous allons une catastrophe majeure et
vous m'interrogerais sur bientôt ça sera
est-ce que la poussée du mouvement
xénophobe en allemagne va gagner eh ben
je vous réponde avance oui parce que
comme c'est un pays où la condition des
familles est ce qu'elle est où il est
difficile d'avoir des enfants et d'avoir
une carrière professionnelle il ya peu
d'enfants qui naissent en allemagne pour
compenser la baisse démographique y font
une immigration qui va faire exploser la
société allemande
vous le verrez c'est l'histoire est
écrite pour les trois prochaines années
alors on verra avant est d'abord la peur
que l'on a franchement j'aimerais
tellement près jean luc mélenchon en
russie dernière hommage aujourd'hui à
l'opposant boris nemtsov est assassiné
ce week-end est ce qu'on peut encore
être un opposant en russie sans prendre
des risques considérables
ah ben ça c'est au risque il faut le
demander moi je suis persuadé que le
gouvernement russe va prendre les
mesures pour que les coupables soient
attrapés
parce que à part ce malheureux qui est
mort et sa famille qui en souffrent la
victime politique numéro un de cette
histoire c'est monsieur poutine lui-même
parce que quelle idée comment peut-on
imaginer qu'il irait aussi un opposant
si non ceux qui sont responsables du
climat de haine politique c'est tous les
nationalistes d'une manière générale qui
est bon alors là je pense que cet homme
là bas il défend son pays c'est quand
même assez normal surtout quand il est
élu il se sent lui victime d'une
agression et de fait il y au moins une
agression sur un point c'est que les les
américains et l'union européenne n'ont
pas tenu la parole qui a été donnée
lorsqu'on a accepté la réunification de
l'allemagne qui était que les frontières
de l'otan s'arrêterait je vous rappelle
qu'à l'époque il était même question que
même l'allemagne de l'est ne soient pas
inclus dans les frontières de l abc dont
les l'union européenne et les américains
ont toujours menti et évidemment ils
tombent
comment s est pas l'irak s'est pas
l'afghanistan c'est par un petit pays
n'est pas en état de se défendre
c'est une grande puissance par
conséquent
monsieur poutine met en place les
éléments qui me paraissent à lui au
portant après il ya une ambiance
effroyable de nationalisme dans cette
zone mais à qui la faute à ceux qui ont
créé des conflits
mais pas vladimir poutine un nom à mon
avis non à mon avis non là par exemple
dans le cas de la russie plutôt à
l'extrême droite qui sans doute a une
responsabilité dans l'assassinât de ce
monsieur qui faisait des manifestations
prévues genyen qui est le responsable
je rappelle que quand même cet homme
comme qui est maintenant dépeint comme
un saint est l allié d'un antisémite
notoire monsieur un aven ce qui je crois
n'a walsky ou style pardon qui a été
candidat à la mairie bal à alexeyev
navalni pardon qui est un antisémite
notoire et c'est avec lui qu'il appelait
à la manifestation qui a eu lieu
dimanche dernier
donc autant je vais comme toulon dire
qu'il est inadmissible on assassine
quelqu'un dans un pays quelconque
d'ailleurs vous savez je retente ne
voulait pas accuser vladimir que non et
je ne veux pas non plus transformer en
ce1 quelqu'un qui à mes yeux ne l'est
pas du tout car il a vendu son pays
ce monsieur est utile mais pardon un
mois encore et des indignations sont
très sélectives 1 il ya un homme qui
tous les vendredis accompli une peine
2000 coups de fouet pour avoir tenu un
blog n'est là monsieur obama téléphone
par monsieur hollande
motus et bouche cousue dernière question
très rapidement de cette partie jean luc
mélenchon 4 parlementaires sont partis
en syrie l'année dernière la semaine
dernière par dont ils vont rencontrer
bachar el-assad est ce que au nom de la
realpolitik il faut renouer avec le
président syrien mais d'abord commençons
par dire que la personne n'a
parlementaires est sacrée il est mis
sous droit de représenter le peuple
comme il estime qu'il en a reçu le
mandat
bon voilà donc là à les rencontrer le
président syrien
je pense pas qu'ils étaient allés là-bas
pour rencontrer le président syrien mais
si l'on rencontre et pourquoi pas je
vais vous dire c'est pas la realpolitik
tout ceci est une conduite
invraisemblable du dossier aux syriens
la banque pourquoi la france at-elle
supprimer sa représentation diplomatique
ça veut dire qu'on ne parle plus parle
plus avec soin comme beaucoup de pays
non beaucoup d'autres pays on s'en fout
on parle de la france nous avons une
responsabilité en syrie nous avons une
histoire avec les syriens les autres
font ce qu'ils veulent nous français
nous sommes différents donc on me
rappelle quand même
évidemment ne serait ce que pour parler
parce que sinon qu'est ce que ça donne
on sait lee a armé des gens qu'on
retrouve ensuite contre une
wire et qui ont constitué des ch alors
ça c'est très intelligent
est ce qu'on doit pas faire un bilan à
m'ont donné des politiques absurdes
après faut-il parler que monsieur à ça
ne voulait parler et qui sait bien lui
qui est là j'ai deux ans et dit manuel
valls
oui bon et ben et les autres c'est quoi
alors qu'est ce que parce qu'on me dit
on est en train de soutenir une
opposition modérée a reçu une bonne
nouvelle ou et cette opposition modérée
que nous soutenons et comment l'avons
nous soutenons pour l'instant nous avons
aidé ce qu'il ya de pire dans la région
mais on doit continuer à avoir cette
attitude c'est absurde donc visas et des
parlementaires qui vont pour voir si on
peut faire arrêter la guerre c'est ce
dont on a besoin d'une conférence sous
l'égide de l'onu où on décide d'arrêter
la guerre avec qu'ils arrêtent la guerre
ceux qui la font donc forcément monsieur
bachar al assad est sorti du match at il
enfin mettre donc autour de la table ah
ben par la force des choses
jean luc mélenchon vaut mieux mettre
autour de la table que d'avoir sur la
tête on va s'intéresser maintenant à la
gauche de la gauche à ses essais de
recomposition de votre parti jusqu'aux
écologistes sans oublier le parti
communiste capelle prison de la fp notre
partenaire va nous rejoindre sur ce
plateau
mais avant louis xi bilbao si nous aider
à y voir un petit peu plus clair dans
cette opposition de la gauche
le tout sur fond d'élection au
département back puisque dans trois
semaines nous votons louis civile c'est
une gauche dispersée qui se présente aux
élections départementales pour la
première fois le ps fait cavalier seul
les verts ont largement préféré s'allier
avec le front de gauche
cet attelage je représente la moitié de
leur candidature
une alliance de raison il ya des
alliances qui sont sur le terrain dans
les départementales pas d'unification
s'il ya pas de projet partagé oui c'est
pour ça que il n'y a pas de raccourci
ça prend du temps tout simplement la
victoire d'alexis titre à son gré ce
fait rêver la gauche du ps le front de
gauche veut réunir tous les déçus 12
non cette gauche-là cette gauche
nouvelle elle est en marche elle n'est
pas en projet elle est en marche elle a
commencé à émerger et on peut dans le
vote lui donner beaucoup plus de force
aux élections départementales et ça
c'est un fait
seulement les verts sont divisés dans
leur ensemble les parlementaires veulent
rentrer au gouvernement et ne voit pas
vraiment les points communs avec le
front de gauche au niveau national ce
que nous voyons nous les parlementaires
c'est que les convergences avec le front
de gauche même si on les cherche
on a du mal à les trouver je constate
que sur l'énergie voilà c'est une
opposition frontale
le front de gauche
et puis tout dans une logique d'alliance
avec l'ump
c'est vraiment main dans la main avec
l'ump pour défendre le tout nucléaire
le front de gauche cherche aussi a
capitalisé sur le rejet de la loi macron
et a attiré quelques frontières
socialistes qui pour l'instant décliné
l'invitation
les fondeurs sont pas à gauche de la
gauche les frondeurs dans le parti
socialiste ce sont des députés
socialistes qui simplement considère que
la ligne du gouvernement et plus social
démocrate mais plutôt libérale ses
divisions à gauche menace le ps pour les
départementales ils pourraient être
éliminés dès le premier tour dans près
de 400 cantons
difficile de savoir si le front de
gauche en tirerait profit dans un
dernier sondage il totaliserait 9% des
intentions de vote avec nous vos
questions à jean luc mélenchon est
dénoué voir un petit peu plus clair déjà
sous vos rapports avec le front de
gauche on se souvient vous étiez sortie
très meurtrie des municipales notamment
être le comportement de votre partenaire
le pc qui s'était allié dans beaucoup de
villes avec le ps qu'on est il là
quelques semaines des départementales
alors bon les choses ont bien avancé
d'abord tout ça c'est de l'histoire
ancienne parce qu'il faut aussi savoir
tourner les pages 1 dans dans l'est dans
les disputes même quand elles sont des
disputes légitime avec un fond ce qui
reste baquet ils font rien donc il faut
savoir tourner les pages et s'accorder
on l'a fait d'eux des longs mois de
septembre entre temps nous avons mis en
route du puy pardon pas entre temps dans
ont mis en route un processus très
intéressant qui s'appelle les chantiers
de l'espoir dans lequel vous avez le
front gauche différents partenaires et
europe ecologie les verts mais aussi
nouvelle donne
il ya des partenaires politiques à peu
près de tout ce que tous ceux qui ont
été en quelque sorte dégoûté par le ps
plus ou moins vite
voilà donc ce travail-là s'avance sur un
projet gouvernemental et on sait très
bien qu'il ya des difficultés alors à
l'instant avec une certaine mauvaise foi
était évoqué le front gauche qui à
l'assemblée nationale votre comme ci ou
comme ça bon non à l'assemblée nationale
ce sont les députés du parti communiste
membre du front de gauche qui suivent la
ligne de leur parti qui est en effet
pro-nucléaire bon tout le monde le sait
donc il ya là des difficultés qui sont
devant nous qui va falloir regagner leur
centre ont partagé les écologistes mon
parti et pour la sortie du nucléaire par
exemple donc et pourtant je suis aussi
front gauche que les députés mais
regarder en face les difficultés
toujours plus commode que deux ne donne
pas le faire donc il ya un processus
comme l'a dit pierre laurent et je
partage totalement ses formulations 7
cette nouvelle gauche elle est en
construction voilà bon ça prend du temps
maintenant on a une étape en route qui
s'appelle le département par les
départementales ça prend du temps mais
là elle arrive à trois semaines à ceux
comme pierre laurent vous parler de déni
de démocratie de manque d'information
des français et de pierres a dit les
choses avec la modération qui lui
correspond vous avec votre modération
oui je vais vous dire comme lui pour
être pour être aussi bien entendu
peut-être que lui mais oui c'est une
c'est quelque chose de totalement
inadmissible d'abord ces gens au
gouvernement ont tripoté la carte change
et les départements dit qu'il n'existait
plus depuis qu'il s'est installé vous
empêche d'utiliser 10 avant de nous
critiquer on pourrait peut-être faire
votre bilan si au passage
mais commençons par ça d'abord il ya
l'autorité du pouvoir maintenant ça
compte dans une société c'est pas un jeu
des institutions d'un pays
vous remarquerez que dans ce pays on
change tout on n'a jamais la vie du
peuple et quand moi je parle de faire
une sixième république donc une
assemblée constituante en bedia quelque
chose étrange non les gens qui a décidé
qu'on supprime évoquant ton que vous
connaissez depuis depuis deux siècles
bref on a donc tout chambouler personne
n'y comprend rien les gens ne vont pas
retrouver leur canton ils ne savent pas
s'ils vont se rendre dans leur canton
pardon est ce qu'ils les connaissaient
rien ça dépend en ville non parce que
les cantons sont aberrants et qu' il ya
longtemps qu on aurait dû
d'autre part vous dit pas tout fait pour
rendre ce scrutin finalement illisible
oser des électeurs je crois parce qu'au
début l'intention du gouvernement était
de supprimer les départements ça fait
une telle levée de boucliers qu'ils ont
été obligés de les rétablir
et surtout ça devenait absurde organiser
une élection pour une structure qui
allait disparaître mais donc oui je dis
comme pierre en plus je peux vous dire
une chose avant les résultats annoncés
par le ministère de l'intérieur
le soir du vote ne voudront rien dire
parce qu'une nouvelle fois ils ont
tripoté là dedans la dernière fois aux
élections municipales j'avais protester
contre le fait que les ministres de
l'intérieur se donne le droit
d'attribuer aux à une étiquette pour une
autre juste à côté de mes amis se
retrouvent et divers gauche tu parles si
on fait divers gauche alors les a
retrouvés divers-gauche chaque fois que
le ps était quelque part c'était union
de la gauche ou de chiny bref et là
maintenant tout le monde proteste les
verts le front de gauche tout le monde
il n'y a que le ps était content de son
petit le tripotage alors vous m'avez
posé la question où en est le front de
gauche
il avance dans la direction dans
laquelle il doit avancer c'est à dire
vers son propre dépassement est allé
sélectionné rame en panne avec une
ouverture vers les écologistes
on l'a vu huy qui ne sont pas tous
d'accord non plus eux aussi se divisent
justement sur la question de la
participation avec le fonds ne sais quoi
l'avenir parce que il ya des
départementales il va y avoir les
régionales oui on sait très bien vous
voulez la 6ème république mais pour
l'instant on est toujours en cinquième
c'est que c'est quoi la v comment vous
reconstruire la gauche du ps on y trouve
normalement on devrait surtout si on
voulait faire l'effort on se retrouve à
aimer ce bon ça il faut bien la fosse et
aussi de la rigolade du spectacle vous
dites il faut du temps oui mais les
échéances et mes patrons voulant allumer
mais si nous avons les échéances
électorales ne sont pas un handicap
la démocratie n'a jamais été un handicap
tout le monde est mis au pied du mur de
s'adresser au peuple
premièrement le peuple il n'en a rien à
faire de cette histoire et vous allez
avoir une abstention massive qui
prolonge ce que je appellerait c'est pas
la bonne expression mais la grève
civique
le peuple s'est retirée sur l'aventin
comme au moins 1 489 de notre ère où la
plèbe a dit ben écoutez les patries
science a suffi roi on va sur le fond
les gens deuxième élément nous allons
avoir dans cette élection pour la
première fois un événement très
important c'est que dans la moitié des
cas les membres d'europe écologie les
verts vont être allié soit avec tous
gauche c'est le cas de l'oise par
exemple ou avec tel ou tel segment du
front de gauche par conséquent sur le
terrain les connivences se construisent
vous savez la politique c'est aussi une
main et surtout ce qui est plus
important mais qui n'apparait pas la
dent dans le reportage et je veux vous
faire savoir c'est que partout nous
avons en commun souvent europe écologie
et nouble parti de gauche
l'idée que ce sont des assemblées de
citoyens qui pilote la campagne désigne
les candidats
vous verrez que cette recette à faire
merveille donc le soir de leurs
résultats
il y aura le blabla nationale et puis il
y aura ce que chacun va voir dans son
canton qui va se dire ah bah tiens ça a
marché
prenons un exemple l'isère dans l'isère
nous avons un accord parti de gauche
europe ecologie les verts ge pas
pourquoi une communiste sont pas mis là
dedans résultat ils sont sondés à 2% et
zou nous sommes sont des municipales de
groupe je le déplore parce que c'est pas
une bonne idée pour le mouvement
communiste de ce minorisées comme ça et
donc notre alliance avec europe écologie
les verts dans les enquêtes d'opinion
ses 17% autant que le parti socialiste
vous me direz ça n'empêchera pas la
droite de l'emporter bien sûr mais on va
peut-être abordé c'est ce sujet ensuite
j'en suis pour toujours à cette histoire
voilà nous allons il va y avoir des
choses qui vont se créer des mariages
des pacs des unions libres qui vont se
faire sur le terrain et nous aurons des
beaux enfants
j'espère aux élections régionales parce
que là nous allons tous est mis au pied
du mur et aux élections régionales ce
sera le test de vérité combien y
aura-t-il de liste d'union entre le
front de gauche europe ecologie les
verts nouvelle donne et combien d'autres
il faudra d'ailleurs qu'on trouve un
cadre un label commun parce que les
anciens la belle dans cette histoire
commence à être un peu dépassé il faut
dix minutes pour expliquer qui est
membre de ce truc dans ce label est ce
qu'il y aura le npa olivier besancenot
qui refuse le npa refuse de participer
avec vous aux élections mais olivier
besancenot fait un appel pour un métier
comme à contre la loi macron est ce que
vous allez du npa olivier rist est ce
qu'il faut rassembler d'abord le npa
qu'est ce qu'ils ont ils sont
insupportables et très bien alors
personne ne vous demande de les
supporter bon on nous demande pas des
thèmes pea le npa demande pas d'être un
père nous ne demandons pas d'être front
gauche
au demeurant si j'ai bien compris le
sens de leur dernier congrès sont pas
d'accord entre eux sur l'ampleur et la
limite bon de d'accord qu'il faut avec
le front de gauche est ce que je peut
pointer du doigt au moins cette réussite
du front gauche et qu'il est centrale
pourquoi parce que y'a pas il n'y a pas
un autre camp possible où vous êtes dans
l'opposition et vous fait une
proposition constructive et positive
vous essayez d'être majoritaires ou bien
vous êtes le gouvernement mais entre les
deux il ya rien final le la colonne
vertébrale de ce rassemblement c'est
qu'on être contre le gouvernement compte
la finale c'est le seul point commun
non non non non non non non vous vous
trompez on voit ce fait vous avez raison
attendez vous avez raison dire on le
voit sur le nucléaire et rebelote le
nucléaire c'est bon oui nous sommes
d'accord chez les socialistes les
écologistes en mer vendée je veux doit
d'abord oui mais moi je suis aussi pour
la sortie du nucléaire dont je suis pas
embarrassé par la question
je sais comment y répondre et je finirai
par en convaincre je l'espère les
écologistes mais prenons les choses
comme elles sont bien sûr que
l'opposition au gouvernement et à la
politique est pratiqué est un
dénominateur commun sinon on n'y serait
au gouvernement et puis bon dans une
démocratie
vous êtes tous dans ou à vec le
gouvernement où vous êtes dans
l'opposition nous sommes une opposition
de gauche
tout le monde n'est pas d'accord avec ce
terme europe ecologie les verts non mais
quand même c'est une réalité mais ce
n'est pas la seule réalité la chose que
ce rien juste si vous réduisiez à ça
parce qu'à plein de propositions
positives qui sont en commun par exemple
sur l'échelle des salaires par exemple
sur l'économie de la mer par exemple sur
la planification écologique ya plein
d'idées en commun et d'ailleurs les
chantiers de l'espoir que nous avons
commencé la 6ème république
les chantiers de l'espoir que nous 20
miles commencer eh bien il travaille à
un projet gouvernemental s'est dit dans
le texte de lancement de ces chantiers
de l'espoir et de dents d'ailleurs il ya
des socialistes qui s'y trouvent
vous avez
monsieur les socialistes à figer
participe au travail vous avez des
secondeurs pardon pas les socialistes
feront n'a pas dû vous savez des
socialistes pas d'accord il ya toutes
sortes de variétés à la fin toute façon
tous passés par le même trou de souris
un ou pour rencontre qu'un tel nicolas
sarkozy l'autre côté de l'échiquier
politique a présenté à esquisser une
politique économique cette semaine et
surtout il a parlé du fn ps
mais j'avoue que j'ai commencé je
comprenais pas de quoi il parlait parce
que bon le ps elle ne le fait il estime
n'avoir fn au premier tour c'est faire
gagner la gauche au second voilà alors
non mais d'accord mais comme c'était
formule et on y avait matière à
confusion
les socialistes sont extrêmement lâché
désagréables à mon égard il m'assimile
assez régulièrement aux extrêmes blabla
pour me renvoyer le même sac que madame
le pen match serait pas pareil avec eux
parce que le parti socialiste n'a rien à
voir avec le front national
ce qui est vrai et je comprends que
monsieur monsieur sarkozy s'inquiète
c'est que madame le pen est en train de
siphonner la droite donc mécaniquement
adam nicolas sarkozy dans ce cas
attendez je ne vais pas répondre à ça
parce qu'après ça fera le buzz
mélenchon est d'accord avec sarkozy non
mais l'argent n'est pas d'accord avec
sarkozy il est de gauche sarkozy et de
droite non une fois cette précision
apportée pour essayer d'éclaircir contre
l'enfumage
disons que ils le ce qui est vrai c'est
que quand elle si fun la droite
mécaniquement el salam est en tête et
puis après c'est nous c'est là entre
nous donc le raisonnement de nicolas
sarkozy est vérifié par les faits mais
de là à parler de fn ps
non c'est une monstruosité qui paie pas
qui est admissible
comment prenez-vous a toujours dans la
même logique
monsieur darmanin député maire de
tourcoing qui à l'ump qui apparaît man
to bear a comme d'un tract ambulants
pour le fn justement est ce que c'est je
pense et la tonalité de la campagne qui
comme il ya une ambition dans ce pays du
matin au soir
bon il n'est question que de ça alors
que l'antisémitisme un coup l'islamisme
alors on croirait que de ce pays est
rempli d'antisémite et des d'islamistes
qui se prépare est gorgé les autres et
il ya un ton qui a été pris maintenant
bon moi je suis je suis un homme qui
aime la polémique mais il m'est arrivé
aussi de sans doute de déborder mais là
on entre dans quelque chose qui est qui
nous est à bompas pourquoi est ce que
madame taubira est un tract pour pour le
fn qu'est ce qu'elle a fait qui justifie
sa politique pénale
bon ben non d'abord parce que la plupart
des électeurs du fn ne comprennent pas
ce qui se passe vu que leur chef leur
explique n'importe quoi non madame
taubira n'est pas un tract contre quoi
que ce soit elle est la responsable
d'une politique pénale par ailleurs
discutable sous l'autorité d'un
gouvernement lui même discutable mais
évitons quand même de vous savez très
bien que ça va au-delà de ce que vous
êtes en train de me dire vous et moi on
a intérêt sur ce plateau à faire
semblant d'avoir compris qu'il voulait
dire un tract anti fn à cause sa
politique pénale
mais la vérité c'est pas ça c'est que y
pense qu'il fait il satisfait une
certaine opinion assez méprisable qui
attachent à madame taubira des mots
indigne que nous avons tous condamnés 1
tout le monde comprend la tour merci
qu'était le prix jean luc mélenchon
maintenant s'intéresser à vos sources
d'inspiration un peu comment vous
renouvelez vos idées c'est un reportage
de jérôme rabier public ce plateau si
pour pierre bourdieu la sociologie est
un sport de combat
la politique l'est encore davantage aux
yeux de jean-luc mélenchon pas une
interview un meeting où une rencontre
sans que cette notion d'affrontements
émergent classe contre classe patrons
contre ouvriers le peuple face à
l'oligarchie tel un stratège il se
réfère très souvent à louis 9 à cette
vision un petit peu d des conquêtes et
des batailles
il emploie souvent le terme de tenir la
tranchée à certains moments puis à
certains moments passe à l'offensive
il m voilà avoir une vision stratégique
de la politique mais pour ceux qui le
connaissent jean luc mélenchon ne joue
pas la comédie c'est tout simplement son
engagement total qui l'amène à
s'enflammer autant c'est pas un combat
voilà pour amuser la galerie on n'est
pas là en train de faire du spectacle
qu'on est en train de parler de choses
fondamentales qui qui concerne l'avenir
de l'humanité
alors on pourra peut-être venir à vous
avez peut-être tort de ça vous touche
autant oui ça nous touche autant parce
que ses courses ailleurs qu'on fait de
la politique c'est qu'on a envie
d'éviter le pire d'un combat permanent
qui mène jean luc mélenchon sur tous les
fronts fort de ses 11 % la
présidentielle de 2012
il s'en va défier marine le pen aux
législatives à hénin-beaumont échoué à
se qualifier pour le second tour
puis il fait de la politique socialiste
tendance libérale sa nouvelle cible
privilégiée une diversité dans ces
combats qui se retrouve également dans
ses sources d'inspiration ça a été les
marche citoyenne inspiré de l'amérique
du sud
ça a été le front de gauche inspirée de
die linke ça a été la tentative d'une
majorité alternative et d'une opposition
de gauche inspirée de syriza et
récemment ça a été le mouvement pour la
6ème république il a ainsi qu'il note il
s'est inspiré très profondément à partir
de l'expérience de podemos en espagne
autant de mouvements qui s'appuie
toujours sur la personnalité d'un leader
charismatique qui leur permet d'émerger
qu'ils s'appellent chavez type race ou
mélenchon une contradiction pas toujours
facile à assumer
quand on promet une sixième république
sans figure de l'homme providentiel
il ya une vraie difficulté c'est de
combattre le principe de la vème
république avec notamment un président
élu qui se comporte comme un monarque et
en même temps de passer par la vème
république pour conquérir le pouvoir par
le suffrage universel parce que nous on
voit pas quel autre moyen de cancale
pouvoir prend ça comme notamment parle
de révolution citoyenne à travers le
phénomène de constituants de condé font
donc c'est une vraie difficulté
une difficulté qui oblige jean luc
mélenchon a toujours repartir au combat
en première ligne avec en point de mire
2017 où il pourrait se représenter aux
risques de personnaliser à l'outrance au
combat presque de se présidentialiser
info
c'est pas faux départ chaussée et s'est
fait partie des parades homme de la
situation nationale y est ça une très
bonne lecture une bonne référence
il s'est trompé sur 1 victoire je ne
suis pas louis 9 céline jacobine qui
rendait la justice
oui c'est pas il s'est contenté pas de
ça il a également mis un signe
distinctif aux juifs inventé la
persécution des hérétiques par le
percement de la langue au fer rouge et
chasser et fait des débuts chez de
glowria ferrand je vous invite tous à
lire la magnifique de la magnifique
biographie de paul murray kendall qui
est un monument qui donne le goût pour
les historiographes des historiens anglo
saxons ont tous les défauts mais ils ont
une qualité énorme quand il raconte
notre histoire
ils la comprennent joli sur la fin du
sujet on laisse supposer l'hypothèse
d'une candidature 2007 qui vous pouvez
me répondre
parce qu'aujourd'hui vous avez une idée
ou pas non parce que la situation était
très mouvante je vais pas faire
l'innocent je suis dans la petite liste
de ceux qui peuvent être candidats pour
notre prochain pas l'expression gauche
de la gauche parce que ça suppose que le
ps est bien plus à gauche qui ne l'est
en réalité
donc si on va en appel sa l'autre gauche
même ça serait ennuyeux mofaz oui mais
il faut il faut surtout magie on vous a
dit j'ai le goût des idées de la théorie
et de cohésion la stratégie oui du
combat je pourrais expliquer ce qui a
été dit la musique je leur ai d'abord
répondre précisément à cette question je
sais que nous sommes dans une situation
extraordinairement mouvante
extraordinairement comme rarement dans
notre histoire
le choc qui va venir sur la france peut
arriver d'un événement guerrier par
exemple ukraine la russie je pars quoi
un accident dans une centrale nucléaire
là bas je rappelle qu'un à 7 ans notre
char mobile quelque chose de cette
nature
le choc peuvent venir de l'union
européenne vous avez vu qu'ils ont serré
d'un cran la gorge gouvernement et
chaque coup venir de l'intérieur sait et
il peut venir
derrière donc du peuple c'est très
émouvant pardon du peuple comme vous
l'appelez évidemment évidemment parce
que pour l'instant qu'est ce qu'il ya
sur la stabilité
les gens sont bons ne vont pas voter
tout ce qui tient pour l'instant le
peuple français c'est que la classe
moyenne
ça chante instruite bon toute cette
classe moyenne pense qu'elle va encore
s'en tirer dans le cadre du système tant
qu'elles pensent ça il y aura de la
stabilité enfin le quand elle cessera de
le croire
comme tous autre âge avec mélenchon le
peuple aujourd'hui c'est ce sont les
personnes qui ne font pas voter c'est ça
non j'ai fait un livre qui s'appelle le
ler du peuple pour montrer que
l'ancienne perception que nous avions du
changement profond de la société en nous
appuyant sur une classe sociale qu'on
avait d'ailleurs beaucoup de mal à
décrire le prolétariat transformer en
salariat après et c'est qu' il fallait
avoir un angle de vue beaucoup plus
large parce que la société était assez
homogénéiser quant au fait que la
plupart des gens ne possède pas leurs
moyens de production autrefois y avait
les paysans et comme air malta et donc
le peuple et ce peuple urbain
essentiellement ou urbanisées audry
robin qui a des conditions de vie et des
exigences assez similaire que les très
riches n'ont pas l'oligarchie son fils
et se fait ce qu'ils veulent comme ils
veulent mais par exemple les classes
moyennes puisque j'en parle et où les
travailleurs ont besoin d'hôpitaux
publics d'écoles de routes en bon état
de réseaux bon voilà et ça c'est un unis
siens extrêmement profond à quoi
s'ajoutent les réseaux sociaux qui sont
des unificateur culturelle qui fait que
vous êtes dans la présence concrète de
tous vos amis sur facebook à quand vous
voulez vous parlez de vos inspirations
vous avez dit dans une émission très peu
de temps que vous n'étiez pas forcément
un homme politique ni un politicien mais
plutôt un intellectuel est ce
qu'aujourd'hui la politique politicienne
nous intéresse encore alors certains
aspects et bon je suis je milite depuis
tellement de temps je n'ai pas dire non
plus je ne vais pas faire le jeu pas
quoi là au dessus de la mêlée et la
cuisine ont fait pas de bombe encaissons
bonne cuisine dont il ya des rouge et
noir en cuisine et des fois il faut oui
il faut bon le corbeau l'iss est passé
du goût tant que ça ce sont des parents
humaines sont bons mais c'est vrai que
je fais de la politique
à la manière peut-être bon d'un
intellectuel parce que je me réfère
toujours à la théorie et quant à théorie
ne correspondent pas aux faits
contrairement aux autres je ne m'acharne
pas et j'essaye de voir où ça cloche et
je rectifie l'angle de vue j'écris des
livres j'ai écrit le livre qu'ils s'en
aillent tous j'ai décrit un phénomène
fondamental de nos sociétés toutes nos
sociétés viendront aux poings
qu'ils s'en aillent tous nathan j'écris
un livre sur l'art du peuple pour
décrire comment le peuple
là je fais une expérimentation le
mouvement pour la 6ème république il va
élire une assemblée représentative 4
formidable c'est que dès que c'est un
peu internet ça passe sous les radars de
tous les observateurs politiciens
traditionnels c'est mieux comme ça il me
fiche une paix royale comme ça
qu'avez-vous fait seulement 20 pour les
expérimentations il vaut mieux et là on
a un mouvement qui va élire des députés
je m'attendais pas à ce qu'il y en ait
autant que soit candidat 600 candidats
nous faisons un tirage au sort je me
disais on va avoir un mal de chien à ce
que des gens alors que tu vois un loyer
ce sont les ados sociaux parce que là
vous avez donné la maladie bien sûr de
nos listes parce que attendait pardon de
vous dire une chose pour notre cas nous
il ya un grand débat
de quoi est fait le futur la formule
syriza c'est à dire une coalition de
partis qui devient un parti ou bien un
mouvement hors cadre appuyez uniquement
sur l'énergie des réseaux populaires
nous n'avons pas la réponse en france
moi je pense que sa religion
moi je me faisais deux mois la tradition
républicaine c'est le peuple d'abord
donc je n'idéalise pas les forme
partidaire mais je sais qu'elles sont
indispensables même fumant de la partie
alors le front de gauche en ce moment on
travaille sur les institutions j'avais
une question très pc on est ici au sénat
vous savez que ça on a pris un petit
peuple à la tête c'est d'aller temps sur
l'institution sénat oui critiques
justifiées ou pas alors oui j'étais plus
jeune sénateur
absolument oui et maintenant voilà un
mois j'étais le plus jeune maintenant je
commence à être bien institutions oui je
connais bien l'institution je connais la
qualité des gens qui la composent mais
ça ne vaut pas un blanc-seing du reste
c'est que le sénat correspondent les
deux chambres correspond à une vision de
l'organisation de la société qui remonte
au xviie siècle qu'est ce que je dis
plutôt que ça du septième ciel me trompe
qui a été inventé par les anglais qui
ont fini par lâcher du lest à
l'expression populaire en créant la
chambre des communes mais il y avait la
chambre des lords qu'à l'époque la
france c'est autre chose parce que le
fait qu'ils aient deux assemblées pour
parfaire le circuit législatif est une
chose je veux bien entraîné un débat
beaucoup ici les gens disent nous
représentons les territoires les
territoires non la politique représente
toujours la population des territoires
n'ont pas d'existence autre que par les
populations qui le composent par
conséquent il y a
dans le bicamérisme quelque chose qui a
toujours choqué les républicains
fondamentaux font comme moi qui est de
dire ma faille a qu'une représentation
possible du 2 avril fait partie des gens
par exemple il trouve aberrant que y ait
deux conseillers généraux par canton
parce que lequel représente le souverain
nous respectons que si on fait du sénat
alors haussé crime vous le gardez vous
le mixer avec un autre institution
d'autre part il faudrait si on devait
avoir une discussion 6 aux deux chambres
parce qu'il ya des arguments pour ça on
pourrait dire mais quelle est la
séparation ou la coupure sonda mentale
dans la société est ce que c'est les
territoires et populations tout ça c'est
un autre siècle
c'est une autre période c'est à un autre
âge de la vie politique est d'accord
pour dire qu'il faudrait fermer la
maison je suis d'accord pour dire qu'il
faut changer la vème république les
conditions d'élection l'assemblée
pourrait par exemple imaginer une
chambre qui soit entièrement élus à la
proportionnelle et l'autre au scrutin
majoritaire de manière à ce que on est à
la reconstruction concret voilà c'est
des choses qu'on peut faire mais il faut
pas que ça devienne le fait que c'est la
république elle-même qu'il faut changer
pour une raison pas seulement parce
qu'elle est ce qu'elle est une monarchie
républicaine mais surtout pour une autre
raison c'est quand le peuple refondre la
république qui se refonde lui même et le
peuple français a besoin de se refonder
comme un peuple à et indivisible est pas
un mélange de religion de couleur de
peau et toutes ces fadaises nous ce
week-end actuellement sur keller
question dernière question vous avez vu
que le conseil de l'europe a réprimandé
la france parce qu'on avait regardé la
fessée et la gifle
qu'est ce que vous en pensez conseil de
l'europe
il faut écouter ces choses là tout le
monde comprend on peut les faire avancer
on n'a pas besoin d'être fustigée enfin
écoutez franchement on a autre chose à
faire
alors la fessée c'est pas une bonne idée
est ce que disent les pédagogues j'en
sais rien je n'arrive pas bien à donner
des fessées ça n'était pas possible pour
moi j'ai bien vu que d'autres le faisait
lever papa cruauté ou manque d'amour
tout le contraire donc il se trompe on
leur explique
bon et puis les choses peuvent évoluer
maintenant que la france a montré du
doigt pour la fessée est franchement
l'agent non de le garder de cos
mêle-t-il non le conseil de l'europe
c'est une institution qui a son intérêt
qui est là et il est là bon voilà quoi
franck ribéry footballeur français à
leurs questions s'il veut être allemand
c'est sous choix qu'il a offert
l'allemand mais qui ne fait pas les deux
voilà je pense que il commet une erreur
les deux pas double nationalité j'aime
pas trop ça d'accord mais je sais que ça
existe dans des conditions qui sont
inextricables par exemple certains pays
refusent de retirer la nationalité à
leurs ressortissants même s'ils ont une
autre par exemple le royaume du maroc
considère que tout marocain de parents
marocains et marocains lui-même bomb ou
ligue i face les gens alors les gens ils
s'arrangent
mais je connais de très bons français
qui ont une carte d'identité
un passeport marocain aussi par là même
une ministre qui dans ce cas là ça ne
m'empêche pas d'être une bonne ligne est
bien française donc ne faut pas trop
s'exciter là dessus cependant ce ribéry
doit les faire l'allemand pour quelle
raison s'il vous plaît pourquoi pour les
jo à pékin je ne sais pas une bonne idée
de faire l'allemand quand on est
français
merci michael merci jean luc mélenchon
d'avoir été notre invité cette semaine
dans preuve par 3 par un pamphlet sur le
chemin je commence ma pub ma promo me
faire si d'avoir été notre invité très
bonne soirée à tous sur l'antenne de
public sénat la semaine prochaine c'est
emmanuel sauf la patronne des verts qui
sera notre amitié